hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control
ia.l2-3.5.1 identify system users
processors acting on behalf of users and
devices
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist SP 10171 compliance stuff
on top of an already colossal workload
well I've got great news for you you
found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it so
cmmccontrolia.l2-3.5.1 identify system
users processes acting on behalf of
users and devices now this is an
interesting control for a few reasons
first is that you would think that this
is just something that is built into
virtually any software system but as it
turns out there are many instances where
you may have a shared computer
environment great examples may be Labs
manufacturing production floors and
other open format offices so because of
that nist mandates that if the computer
can access cui you must be able to
individually identify who is using the
machine somehow this can definitely
create some comp applicated scenarios
but the good news is we have been able
to find solvency for every one of them
if you have a complicated work
environment and need to meet this
requirement I like to invite you to give
us a call and speak with one of our
compliance experts who can help with the
answer to your specific scenario again
it's not okay to just have open
workstations that people work on you
have no idea who's really behind the
keyboard you have to solve for that with
nist there are definitely ways to do it
and we can help but for now let's look
and see what the assessors are looking
for and we'll throw some sample answers
your way to make life a little easier so
three assessment points you're looking
for on this one number one determine if
system users are identified so do you
know who your users are uh that one's
pretty easy system users are identified
by privileged identity management and
active directory that's a great one uh
again can you use local user accounts I
don't see why not as long as you've got
a seam solution that can actually track
that uh assessment Point number two
determine if processes acting on behalf
of the users are identified processes
acting on behalf of users are identified
via the same solution so again we've
already gone through in previous videos
what the seam solution is in case you're
new to our channel it's security
information and event management and if
you don't know what that is that might
be a sign it's time to call us all right
assessment Point number three determine
if devices accessing the system are
actually identified devices identified
via system logs sent to seam solution
active directory IP address and Mac
address so again there's a lot of
different ways to identify the device
itself that's accessing it again IPM Mac
address are definitely there and those
things get logged in your semen ad and
all kinds of other places so again I
want to make sure we can identify not
just the people the pro but also the
processes and of course the devices as
well so uh an on-call if uh if you're
new to our videos we help defense
contractors just like you who have had
this dfars nist itar and cmmc compliant
stuff dropped in their laps like a seal
on a sunny day we teach you how to level
up and be a proper on-call compliance
hero for your company eliminating gaps
great areas and getting this solved all
while showing you how to leverage
compliance is your secret weapon to land
more Defense work with higher profit
margins now that's what becoming an
on-call compliance hero can do for you
if you're looking for more help getting
compliant our compliance experts are
always on call for you you can visit
cmfccompliance secrets.com or check out
the bio below for links to get help
right now if you love the content we're
putting out there for you help us out
the big thumbs up on that like button or
even better smash the Subscribe button
to get the latest compliance content as
soon as our compliance Center is rolling
out until next compliance tip my friends
stay safe and secure out there hit us in
the comments below to let us know what
you'd like to know more about when it
comes to information security and
compliance and I'll see you on the next
one
[Music]
all right